so okay now that we've done all that
now that we've done all that
um
let's uh let's move on bro yeah you were
missed in new york bubba was i yeah i
always think about you in new york i
can't believe you kind of came up there
it's such a special song oh my god dude
you can do five sets tonight in new york
god man that's where the grind happened
dude there's i watched chris de seveno's
special last night yeah how good it is
hilarious beshte weshy i love him he's
the best he's so fun i went to his house
but he's doing a special and just
[ __ ] around he's improvising i mean
he's you know what stefano has
he's like this big handsome dude
who's got tremendous vulnerability and
he's just so vulnerable he's so [ __ ]
great man i i felt so good out there you
know with the flagrant two team and then
with uh distefano and then by the way i
want to say this is on your side yeah i
know i love schultz dude these two here
yeah when you shoot your special you go
to new york
there's this podcast called called are
you garbage and akash on flagrant 2
because i go hey man this is my schedule
am i missing anything he goes you have
to do are you garbage i don't know them
i knew of them because mark norm was on
there and schultz and tim dillon and so
i don't know he goes he goes they're
they're getting big but and they're two
guys from the the seller that they got
passed and they're funny man it's
different show you might have fun let me
know if you can do it here's his number
he connects with kevin the guy on the
right
before i decide to do it i reached out
to every comic i know in new york
several comics
every and again
the respect of your peers is everything
every comic in new york goes
these two are the best they're great
comedians their podcast is the funnest
you're gonna
have out here definitely do it so i tell
them i go hey man my schedule is packed
dude and he goes
whenever you can do it we'll make time
for i go i can only do that 8 p.m on
monday night i do two shows before that
i'll do yours at eight exhausting yeah
but fun yes and they go we're in so me
him talking about great guy i'm like
that's weird how nice he is
you do their show and you know you do
we've done a million shows oh this is
garbage are you garbage so what they are
you guard so this is the format of the
show the formula of the show is they
they go through your childhood and what
you the way you were raised and at the
end they tell if you're garbage we found
out i was garbage three minutes in
the way i was born i was like well
should we end it now and they're having
so hard they're so funny it's so
different
i got in the taxi that night hmm i got
the tax that night because they remind
me of us
if you remember when we were at fox
sports and you could feel there was like
what we had was special and we were
coming up and we knew we were on to
something big and
everybody told you not to do it with me
and you know this podcast this this
pocket stuff is stupid it's going
nowhere in hollywood doing these tv
shows and we we just ignored all of it
we kept doing it
and when i i got in the car i had tears
in my eyes and
they right now they're like they're just
like us on the cusp of blowing the [ __ ]
up and they're two comics and they all
all they have is each other and one
other guy and i i text him i said you
guys are gonna be so big man and you
guys have something so original and so
special and i've been there and
i'm i suck at this
stop and smell the roses what you guys
are doing and that they leave the next
day because they're doing just like us
they're doing the podcast on the road at
comedy works in denver doing one show
just like us yes and i told him i said
dude i'm telling you
you guys can be huge you're gonna get
through making all the money in the
world but what you're doing right now
the come up right now is everything try
to embrace it it's the magic yeah it's
the magic and they're the dude you know
how it is when you meet people they're
just so genuine and like good people man
and you want the best for them and their
show so original so fun
kevin and foley they're just such good
people so cool yeah i think the episode
just dropped today and it's so fun man i
told them i said this is the funnest
time i've had i don't know how long
they'll really you do rogaine do i i
know but i've done that before and you
know i'll see that's a different kind of
dance what you guys do nobody asked me
questions it's always me promoting
something or you and i [ __ ] around
or mean theo roasting somebody like for
you to dive into my childhood and then
if i'm garbage and bring up memories
i've totally forgot about it this is i
had so much fun man it made my [ __ ]
trip that's so good made my trip it's so
great yeah it was so funny yeah that's
that magic and it comes down to loyalty
and it comes down to connection and
really what you're talking about is
intimacy
that what happens when you go through um
[ __ ] with somebody over 10 years
is it you develop a real bond of
intimacy now some bands break up
some bands can't take it because ego
gets in the way yeah we're not like
errol smith where we don't talk
we always [ __ ] air it out we fight we
talk but we're not the same we'll be mad
for a minute yeah then after that well
we come back to the truth of the
situation right we come back to was i
wrong here yeah and was i you know you
got to do that man you got to do that in
life for better or for worse in your
relationships